people who otherwise were probably very
sane and you know living in the world in
a secular world will do crazy things to
make it seem like they're good a lot of
it has to do with this notion that
religion has essentially religion
essentially has co-opted morality and
ethics and that therefore if you're
higher up in the church you deserve more
respect in some way shape or form and I
think it's related to a lot of that I
think a lot of our sad we separate that
because when when I hear people say that
it seems so obvious to me that that that
has so little to do with reality when
you think of the wars that have been
fought in the name of religion the
amount of people who have been killed in
name of religion well I think the
alliteration and all kinds of awful
things these things probably a lot of
them would happen without religion or
wouldn't I mean religion wants to make
itself bigger ok religion wants to make
itself more important than it is ok
religion is just the belief in an
invisible man in the sky and religion
knows it so it puts it tries to put its
fingers where it can't be where it is
and so that you know you have two arms
well you have two arms because you're a
Jew you're welcome you're a good person
because you're religious you're welcome
if you're one of the out-group you don't
have this religion is so important to
you it's much more than an invisible man
in the sky believe that's the way
religion entrenches itself and makes
people fear leaving it it's actually a
really scary function of brainwashing
that it actually makes people fear
leaving it by making people fear the
out-group by assuming a much bigger role
in their lives than it really should
right and then it I think has a lot to
do with the power structure I mean
certainly again coming from a Catholic
background I'm very aware that you know
Catholicism the church is basically a
military and geopolitical structure and
you know the church was a was a power
structure it has a city state thanks to
mostly nee by the way but that's a whole
other thing I mean you know the church
was was a well if not gloss over that
the church literally has a city-state I
mean it literally is dating it is by the
Vatican by arrangement with Mussolini
because mostly nee wanted the backing of
the church the fascist party wanted the
backing of the church and there was a
lot of political struggle
in there and so an agreement was
hammered out to where the Roman Catholic
Church could go back seven hundred years
to the Middle Ages and have its own
city-state with the blessing of
Mussolini who would leave it alone and
give it all its international Authority
and what-have-you just basically to not
get into a fight with however many
millions of Catholics in Italy but the
power structure of that also I think you
know feeds down to this day and age that
the church feels like it it should be
world power and will do anything it can
to create the illusion of that mm-hmm
and it has a seat on the UN and they
come to they come to to America and they
can't tell us what laws we should pass
can you imagine if the Prime Minister of
France came to America and said we
should change our laws to be more like
them right but when we're tell us what
to do about abortion yeah imagine that
the leader of another state comes here
to campaign for our laws yeah did you
guys see this that just this past week
or a couple days ago Bernie Sanders met
with the Pope and then the Pope issued a
statement after and said it wasn't a
political meeting mm-hmm I thought this
is the craziest thing I've ever heard
we'll talk a little bit about Bernie in
a second who's basically an atheist Jew
or at least not or maybe not a Jew
anymore or whatever however hard to find
that but I thought this is so pandering
from both of these guns yeah you're
telling me that the candidate for
president United States is meeting with
the Pope it's not political yeah you
know when I was a kid
Kennedy was running for president and I
was too young to understand it at the
time but in you know in still very young
this stuff was fresh and I began to
reexamine it the whole issue about him
being a Catholic and would would that
mean that the Vatican is running the US
government because of his commitment of
the Catholicism and all this and all
that and all that argument also
contributed to sort of fraying my belief
and and respect for it all but also
making it very clear that there is a
component about whether or not you
believe there's an invisible man in the
sky and whether in
you go to hell when you die with the
presidency of the United States that
that that clash was so apparent that yes
it became part of that what what is
going on here you know and then as I
grew older I saw that the politics of it
is really what it's all about yeah do
you guys see it that some religions sort
of have easier ways out than other ones
so for example Christianity because
there are you know we have Santa Claus
who everyone realizes isn't real by the
time they're you know five or six or the
Easter Bunny or a couple of these other
things it's almost like a hint to the
kid that there's some made-up stuff here
that's the way I've always viewed it
they're sort of saying to the kid
there's some made-up [ __ ] here and as
you're going to grow old you're gonna
realize some of these other shits made
up to versus Judaism has none of that
and I for me I always remember thinking
if anyhow every Jewish holiday is
basically saying not all of us got
killed
that's right every holiday is that well
we didn't all die there hasn't ever been
all died during perfect or whatever it
is and I always remember thinking during
all the holidays this god I must be
incredibly [ __ ] up but not he didn't
kill all of us and now we have to
celebrate and this is like you know this
is crazy now but there isn't the the
illusion you know there's no there's no
Hanukkah Harry accept on Saturday Night
Live there's no Hanukkah higher but
there is secular Judaism right so you
can you can completely ditch the the
Jewish God and still be called Jewish so
there's that out right okay the the
there's an out that's not an out there's
an okay you don't have to believe but
you're still a Jew mm-hmm and you know I
the the vast majority of Jews out there
still consider me a Jew because you
can't leave according to their religion
I was born to a Jewish mother therefore
I am Jewish by race so there is there's
no way for me to leave so there is there
are no one's gonna kill you for leaving
either which isn't important no one's
going to go for you but I can't leave
because I'm a Jew anyway sister so the
out there is that even if you don't
believe you're still a Jew you're still
an in-group but that also has a lot to
do with the confusion of the religion
yeah and the
nation of origin yes oh it's
deliberately confusing I mean they do it
deliberately Judaism is the only
ethnicity nationality and this is the
reason why it's [ __ ] because it's
it's it's all about special exceptions
you know if you have a person or one
race marries a person of another race
you have a child of a mixed race unless
you're Jewish right because then if the
mother's Jewish you're all Jewish and
it's a race and Judaism is a race and if
you if you have a born person from one
race and he marries another race that
new person doesn't become the first race
unless you're Jewish right but you
couldn't learn you could come from a
black mother and a white father and be
so you're yes but but if you have you if
you have a Jewish mother and a Gentile
father you I fold you right right right
so they just pretend that it's all about
special pleadings it's all about
exceptions to the rule it's like again
think about it like we're saying offline
if you have chicken chow mein is that
Buddhist food is falafel Muslim food no
it's all about locations you know we all
have cultures that are based on
locations based on nationalities based
on borders based on based on fixed
points unless it's Jewish mmm in which
case they just make it up and they call
it oh um what's your nationality oh I'm
Jewish no I am Eastern European from
descent and I have no blood shared with
the Jews from Ethiopia or the Jews from
the Sephardic areas I don't have right
you have but you if you believed you
would have a set of beliefs in common
but not and that's what makes a Jew a
Jew yes the set of beliefs it's the
Torah the only commonality among Jews
Ethiopian Sephardic Ashkenazim is the
Torah not even the Talmud is common so I
mean if you eat the opium Jews wouldn't
know a bagel if it bit them on the ass
Sephardic Jews don't eat bagels lox and
cream cheese they don't have they don't
dance the hora they don't look like me
they don't even have names like mine
right okay it's all Eastern European but
Judaism takes the credit like I said
before you have a culture it's Judaism
you're welcome right so isn't some of
this the trappings of religion though
because you know we can go wherever we
want in this the rest of this
conversation you know but we somehow get
caught up in some of this kind of
stuff right and that's sort of the
danger of this it's hard that's not by
accident yeah that's been designed over
millennia mm-hmm to function that way so
then we take three people that are on
that the commonality is here is that we
are choosing not to believe until there
is evidence how you spread that message
effectively because I think it's
incredibly hard to spread I see it
waking up but I even I've said this on
the show many times when I'm on Twitter
or even in the YouTube comments
that many of my fans who are atheists
are still anonymous and to me that's
like they're in the closet the way a gay
people had to be in the closet for long
time and I really want to help that
transition if I can do anything how do
you how do you deal with some of that
well for me personally and and and there
is a difference in myself and David here
because David has has chosen to get into
the politics of this as a livelihood and
as a mission
I personally on a personal level I
understand well you know how people turn
off to Dawkins and a lot of atheists try
do this that is that I understand where
that comes from I think it's misguided
but I can understand where that comes
from and that's all about form over
content so it's misguided in that
they're they just don't like the
technique that those guys are using
which goes to the same books to a
certain degree from the people that feel
that way often just are offended that
their beliefs are being offended right
you know but for me personally what it
is is I don't try and spread it but I
try to be open and clear about it and if
someone asks me to have the conversation
I will have the conversation I come from
the show not tell school of you know of
this kind of thing which is where if
somebody asks me about it I'll sit but
we'll have a conversation all day long
but I don't care about whether or not
you choose to believe or not believe I
don't get into arguments with Christians
I don't I don't have those arguments
unless I'm invited to have a
conversation and I find that that it
tends to be very effective because the
people who ask me about it knowing you
know that I'm open about it the people
who are asking about it tend to be the
ones who are wondering and doubting
anyway and
then the conversation becomes an
authentic one as opposed to a in real
life trolling sure thing is that I knew
you I've known you now for a couple
years and you know we've smoked weed and
talked about this stuff right and I knew
who you were before I knew you but all
these car I didn't realize you were that
much into this idea and I've had many
conversations with you about this stuff
and it was and we were just I was just I
got Paul is an interesting smart guy and
we're discussing some stuff it's become
more meaningful to me because of
politics it's become more meaning to me
because of the division it's become more
meaning to me as we move into what is
essentially a holy war in 2016 we
understand things about galaxies
thousands millions of light-years away
we're taking photographs of planets
beyond our solar system and we're still
and and there's a religious war
happening on the planet so that's made
the topic more compelling for me and
just the idea of celebrating non-belief
more meaningful it's like it again it's
because not because I'm trying to
convince anybody of anything but because
if you are somebody doubting your faith
or you are somebody who's sitting back
going is this crazy or am I crazy or am
I gonna go to hell because I don't
believe this stuff really and when you
push comes to shove you know to just say
no you're not alone there's a lot of
people out there and you know what
there's a lot of great people that you
can spend time with who aren't going to
hit you with fire and brimstone about
anything yeah I mean that'll learn to do
with living a good life and a decent
life and a moral life and an ethical
life in fact it becomes very clear as
you move away from people who use
religiosity as an example you know as an
illustration of their ethics and
morality everything you begin to see
really how shallow most of it is yeah so
that's the way that's that's what it is
is like unless somebody asked me about
it I don't really have the conversation
yeah so I want to get to that some of
the fake moral stuff but one thing I for
you is why do you think people are so
afraid to just
say I don't know because I don't think
anything that either one of you have
said here or that I've said is anything
really more than that no I don't know I
don't know but and and that doesn't mean
a god did it right the entire right god
argument takes it takes that to the next
up I don't know therefore God did it
right therefore I'm going to make some
stuff up going through someone else I
mean and pretend to believe it I'm going
to believe it or I'm going to pretend to
believe it and you know it Paul was
talking about pushing atheism and he's
right I am on the opposite side of it I
think that promoting atheism is a good
deed yeah okay I see religion as a
poison that is inflicted on children
usually and it's a good thing to help
them away from it the analogy that I use
is is it is it okay if your mother is
poor because my mother was and she was
paying money to a psychic and I sat her
down and I stopped her from going to a
psychic okay I think that's a good thing
for a son to do yeah but when we do that
to religion closely held religious
beliefs people get offended now they've
got the same amount of proof zero okay
the sum total I'm going to make sure I
say this correctly the sum total of
scientifically valid proof for anything
supernatural ever in world history is
zero prove me wrong once and I'll quit
my job and I put that in writing and in
fighting God and people don't like it
when you equate religion down to those
other scams when when you say okay you
know this is a scam - and by the way
your parents were victims of the scam
and your grandparents and they tried to
inflict that stuff on you and it was
wrong of them they thought they were
doing good but people don't like that
because they have to admit that
everybody and their family is wrong and
of course when you're talking about a
believer you're talking about making
them understand that they're going to
die you're talking about making them
understand that everybody who is already
dead is already dead you're also talking
about adults who were raised this was
woven into the fabric of their identity
in their existence from the time they
were watch the language and and it
becomes very very challenging still have
to talk about it right so you need
almost some sort of cognitive this
there you need to say two separate well
my I know my grandma she was a good
woman but yeah it was great yeah but but
but Paul was talking about the
scientists before who believed in not
that that's the same thing you have that
cognitive dissonance because of the
brainwashing that people receive as
their chill as children it's not okay
okay it's not something that we should
find socially acceptable brainwashing
your children into thinking that
something is wrong is right yeah is bad
and we need to own people who we need to
talk to people who do that we need to
call them on their [ __ ] this is child
abuse
and it's not okay and if somebody is the
victim of this brainwashing it is a good
thing to help them away from it it's a
good thing to help them realize the sum
total of proof for anything supernatural
ever is zero so in effect you would say
this is like a parent that by the time
the kid is sixteen is still going abotu
fairy's real a great way to there's real
and if you don't believe it get out of
my house yeah well that's the question
how many of those parents do you think
actually believe the Tooth Fairy is real
I mean in terms of religion you know I
mean how many people write that great
who are instilling this in their kids
actually really do believe it themselves
this is the problem and this is the
problem because see people are so
enthralled with not being atheists that
atheists are drilling religion into
their kids they're joining churches
after they have kids yeah so that they
can inflict their [ __ ] onto those kids
yeah the stuff that they don't even
believe themselves and they think that
that's the moral thing to do because
even as atheists they're still victims
of that same brainwashing that religion
is somehow good I know someone personal
friend of mine who right this very
moment has three kids sending them all
to religious school I'm not going to say
what religion but it's not one of the
not Judaism or Christianity right now
sending there and he's a total
non-believer and he said I'm doing well
make my parents happy
mmm can you have imagined death and this
is someone who I know to be totally
rational totally decent you know this is
somebody who's taking away his
children's ability to designate fact
from fiction to tell fact from fiction
he's literally indoctrinating his
children into something he knows is a
lie in order to please his parents who
still believe in a lie and we don't even
know that they really believe they
because their parents cousin their band
has he asked his parents a lot of
parents don't Blum find out yeah but
even if they do you don't indoctrinate
your children into a lie
that's injuring your children and we
need to call it that if you're teaching
lies to a child and taking away their
ability to tell fact from fiction
you are injuring your children it is a
bad thing to do even if your parents
want you to
you